[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in albert breer the senior
nfl reporter
for the monday morning quarterback ohio
state apologist and uh let's start there
albert how was that day watching
michigan and uh the ohio state yeah it
was tough um it's been a while you know
so i i think 10 years real like i mean i
i say 10 years but like you know as well
as i do like that one 10 years ago
wasn't it's like during the year that we
didn't really have a full-time head
coach luke fickle was the interim
and um so really it's like the first
time i felt that way in 18 years which
is mind-blowing
so
yeah it was frustrating and it was like
it felt like
it felt a little bit like losing to
purdue when we couldn't stop rondale
moore
or losing to iowa when we couldn't stop
the tight ends it's like when another
team has one thing you can't stop
then
it's a really really frustrating
experience and i felt that way with the
michigan pass rushers that
um you know they were pretty much
consistently able to get to cj and keep
our passing game from really hitting the
rhythm that it's been for the last 10
for the last months i know you covered
the nfl but obviously college football
with uh lincoln riley what's happened
with oklahoma and how that we thought
the mel tucker michigan state contract
was going to reverberate with salaries
around college in the nfl
i was told lincoln riley was offered 12
million dollars a year by lsu
how do you think this plays out with
other coaches like you know cliff
kingsbury is probably going to go
hey do i have to flirt with oklahoma or
lsu to get a pay raise here with the
arizona cardinals what do you think
happens
yeah i think it's just sort of changes
the dynamic and
i think there are some people that would
argue dan that it's been a long time
coming i mean if you think about like
what players make and if you want to
really go down the list and look at the
players who are making 10 12 14 million
dollars a year that's what the top
coaches in the nfl make
like there's no argument those guys
aren't as valuable as a great head coach
and it's not knock on any of those guys
it's just having a great head coach is
as valuable i think in pro football as
it is in any sport right
and so
like i think that there maybe has been a
market correction coming here because of
the value of a great coach in that sport
specifically
and um you know i think it started to
some degree with matt rule in that like
he
i think broke the bank for a guy with
his first nfl coaching contract where
you had guys in eight figures and now
they're about i think there are nine nfl
coaches that are on eight figures per
year
but you didn't have a first time guy
coming in and getting nine million a
year the way matt rule did and he didn't
have anybody doing seven year contracts
but matt rule could command that because
that's what baylor was offering him to
stay you know so
um you know i think that that's sort of
gonna be the way the leverage game works
in coaching now where you know these big
college programs especially ones that
are gonna get desperate here like your
oklahoma like your lsu that are afraid
of sort of the music stopping and them
not having a guy
um you know i think a lot of you know
the successful pro coaches all they have
to do
is just be vague with their answers for
a week right like somebody has them at a
press conference just be vague for a
week like i don't know if it's you know
give them the old kyle shanahan like
answer i don't know if we're all gonna
be alive on sunday you know and and just
make your your place a little nervous
and maybe cash in well mike tomlin
wasn't trying to cash in when he wasn't
vague when that story came he basically
gave a speech which i had a usc fan who
said
now we really want him even more with
giving a speech like that i said he gave
you a speech that he doesn't want to go
to usc he goes i mean i love the fire
there i what kind of openings you know
it was a week ago matt maggie was being
fired reportedly okay still got his job
i expect him to be let go at the end of
the year
vic fangio is kind of winning his way
into a
it feels like a tougher decision in
denver i don't know if joe judge is
you know these next four or five games
are going to impact his future there
don't know if you see any other
openings or potential openings i mean
there's been so much turnover you know i
feel like this is like an annual thing
dan where we get to this time of year
and unless there are the obvious ones
and like last year was different because
last year we really had like three stays
of execution right like detroit atlanta
jacksonville those guys all survived
after 2019 and they were on a very very
short leash going into 2020
and you know obviously all of those come
open but there's been so much turnover
over the years that sometimes it's hard
to pinpoint you know which ones are
going to be open this early because
you're firing guys who've only been in
their places for a year or two you know
but i think the ones that most of the
people in the industry are paying
attention to
um you know
obviously you know chicago has won and
you know the fate of a young quarterback
is sort of in the balance there so
that's a big one
minnesota is another one where you know
two years ago
that was sort of up in the air
and you know if they don't make the
playoffs this year be the first time for
mike zimmer missing two years in a row
so i think that that's one to keep an
eye on as well
um you know obviously some of them have
kind of gone the other way like miami is
a good example people were talking about
miami well now you know brian flores and
chris greer and the guys down there have
won four in a row and they play the jets
and the giants the next two weeks and
two is playing well so it looks like
he's safe you know joe judge what does
it look like over the last half of the
season i can tell you this like the
mara's loved jason garrett so the fact
that he
that they were willing to pull the plug
on jason gear in the middle of the
season
you know got everyone's attention in
that building and it should you know i
think everybody was put on notice by
that so you have a few that are sort of
i think percolating right now
um you know the other thing is i think
you know there's there's to some degree
i think this has happened in college too
where this has sort of forced these big
swings like usc taking a huge swing at
lincoln riley
there aren't the obvious candidates that
were last year like last year you had
robert sala and arthur smith who
everyone interviewed do you have that
obvious like young candidate coming up i
think this is going to be a year where
maybe you see more of the retreads you
see guys like josh mcdaniels or raheem
morris or todd bowles um you know those
sorts of guys getting second shots
because there just isn't the pool of
young candidates than there there has
been in the past we're talking albert
breer senior nfl reporter and lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback
i'm curious about this situation how it
plays out in seattle and i don't have
any inside information on it but i have
a pretty good gut feeling with russell
wilson
if you're not going to make the playoffs
and
the franchise has to decide okay what is
our future what direction are we pointed
in
uh do you want to keep pete carroll does
pete want to stay he's going to be 70
years of age russ has two more years
left
um
could russell wilson
pull up matthew stafford
could he say hey
let's let's just you guys get something
for me but let me move on
could you see a scenario
where russ
not forces his way out but maybe
stafford's his way out yeah like he's
less passive aggressive than he was
about it last year i think is what
you're saying right yes yes i mean my
understanding is like so his mindset
last year um having talked to some
people around him was
he wanted to view last year as like the
launch you know the last offseason as
the launch of the second half of his
career and so it wasn't just i'm going
to assess my team it's i'm going to
assess the way i train i'm going to
assess how i work with my teammates in
the off season i'm going to assess all
of this
because
he was i think consumed with the idea
like what's my legacy going to be and am
i going to be remembered like a peyton
manning or a tom brady and to do that do
i have to win championships and so i
mean i'm just here to tell you this dan
like if that was his mindset last year
and he's really worried about like what
his legacy is going to look like and he
views this as the start of the second
half of his career and he wants to have
what tom brady had you know at the end
of new england and now in tampa or what
peyton manning got in denver after he
got hurt and came back from the injury
does he think he can get that in seattle
because if he doesn't at the end of this
year and it's not looking great right
now and tonight might be another one of
those national tv referendums on it like
i don't know where he'd be in more of a
spot in january of 2022
than he was in january of 2021
to want to stay there and so i think
your scenario is an interesting one
because
the way staffer did it was very
i would say it was very it was just very
conciliatory you know where it was i'm
going to go in and i don't want to
ruffle feathers and i don't want to ruin
my legacy in this city and i still love
this franchise and i want you to be able
to bring me back here and put me up in
the ring of honor but i want to move on
and work with me and so like just
knowing how image conscious for us is
yeah i don't think it's that hard to see
a scenario especially if they miss the
playoffs especially if there's questions
about pete's future especially if the
roster doesn't look better in eight
weeks than it does now like going
forward where you know i could see
russell def like going in and having
that conversation because i do think
that there's a lot of people outside of
russell's camp working in that building
that have thought for a while that he's
on his last contract with seattle to
begin with yeah i believe that i don't
think that he plays there next year but
i just wonder and you're you're so dead
on with russ and being image conscious
he's as image conscious as anybody and
you don't want to be that guy who says i
want to force my way out you want to be
the guy who says look you don't have you
know first round draft picks
you know i i want to move on i i want to
try to win another championship and you
guys might not need to rebuild but i
want i just wonder
how much longer russ and pete carroll
can co-exist with their philosophies
when it when it comes to offense and and
if i agree with that that that's an
important point dan too because i think
sometimes we overlook this
like these guys and this isn't like i'm
not like just saying russell because i
don't want to make him sound self brady
cares about this stuff too those guys
really care about their personal
performance right and it's like you
can't like ask a guy like this to shut
down
the competitive nature at like the team
performance
and
like it's okay individual performance
doesn't matter as much because it does
like how they play matters to them
almost as much as winning does and
that's another i think you hit an
important important point there which is
like does he feel like he's in the best
position to become a hall of famer right
like does he feel like he's in the best
position to really be remembered a
certain way and play the sort of game
that maybe he thinks he's capable of he
doesn't think that that's going to
happen in seattle because pete runs the
place a certain way and it's going to be
run a certain way as long as pete's
there
you know that's certainly a part of it
too and i wonder if it's a big market
like the giants let's say
they have two first-round picks
is that something and i don't mean to do
sports radio where you call in with
trade scenarios but i'm just looking at
this because i do think it's going to be
real i do think this is going to happen
but i don't know if russ goes
my wife wants to be in a bigger market
or i want to be in a bigger market if
you want to win you're not going to go
to the giants so where you know could
you go to the saints
you know i mean there's there's a couple
of teams that have that missing
ingredient which could be russell wilson
i mean like i've heard platforms really
important to him you know and and i
think i believe dallas was on his list
yes i mean
you know what i mean like and i heard
chicago this is wild i mean i but but
there was there was like a rumor
floating around last year that he liked
the idea of chicago because that's
obama's team right like and that like
there was platform potentially post
career there and so like i i think he's
very conscious of that stuff too
and obviously new york would be a stage
you know like new york like going and
being the giants quarterback and maybe
being the guy to help resurrect that
team and there are pieces there now they
need to fix a bunch of stuff too but
there are pieces there
like you're kenny galladays cadarius
tony's
evan engrams when he's healthy saquon
barkley where you could look at it and
say
if you drop a veteran quarterback in
there
maybe that veteran quarterback can
ignite that team the way again like a
peyton manning ignited that broncos team
with demurius thomas and eric decker 10
years ago
i
you know if i was at that ravens browns
game i would ask for my money back
that's one of the worst prime time games
i've ever seen but i i don't think he'd
be very successful no i would not be um
i i don't know what to make of the
ravens as much as i look at lamar and
i'm fascinated
and it but it feels like he's a one-off
in the playoffs where you go man he's
really hard to defend
yeah i don't know
if they're closer to being a super bowl
contender than they were last year and
we know cleveland was on a lot of the
short list of playing in the afc title
game here yeah so
they're both kind of interesting the
ravens feel lucky they they sort of
they've survived here which i guess
that's what you want but what are you
are the ravens a super bowl contender i
think these two teams are like in very
different spots i think for the ravens
um
this is about injuries and i give john
harbaugh all the credit in the world i
mean i think he's done a dynamite job
and if they wind up with the number one
or number two seed i think he deserves
coach of the year consideration the
amount of things that they've lost like
running backs are more important to them
than most other teams because the way
they run their offense they lost their
top two running backs jk dobbins and gus
edwards they lost their left tackle
ronnie stanley that's a sort of injury
that can be crippling for teams you know
they lose marcus peters their number two
corner
you know you just you look at the
injuries they've had across the board
and then the kind of ticky tax stuff
that's taking guys out right like where
the receiver room was like basically a
mass unit for two months and you know
lamar goes down and he's out for a game
i just like
it's one of those things where it's like
you know you want to believe they're
going to be able to keep this going but
so much of it feels like smoke and
mirrors and it's a great credit to
everyone in that building that they've
made it work and so i think with the
ravens it's more can we continue to
scotch tape this thing together on a
week to week basis because we are really
really limping here
whereas with the browns i think it's
more
i would just say i think some of the
magic they had in that locker room last
year where they were a gritty
tough
like like there were so many things
about that team last year
that was sort of like all right like
kevin stefanski has the culture turned
there i think with some of the moves
they made in the offseason they lost a
little bit of that and so i think that
they are maybe a little less resilient
than they were last year and obviously
since this is cleveland when things go
even a little bit wrong
because of the history that franchise
the way that teams covered like they
have a way of getting magnified
great to talk to you as always albert
thanks for joining us awesome thanks for
having me dan that's albert breer senior
nfl reporter lead content strategist for
the monday morning quarterback